From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . And I'm not Ira Glass. I'm Alex Blumberg, a producer here. I know I sound a lot like Ira. But trust me, he is away this week.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我不是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我是亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg），本节目的制作人。我知道我的声音听起来很像艾拉，但请相信我，他这周不在。
And I'm really excited to be guest hosting, because I have the opportunity to play one of my favorite pieces of tape we have ever aired on the show. I've been here 17 years. This is one of my all-time favorites. And I have the excuse to play it for you thanks to a 180 that the city of New York is doing.
我非常高兴能担任客座主持，因为我有机会播放我们在节目中播出的我最喜欢的录音片段之一。我在这里工作了17年，这是我个人最喜欢的片段之一。多亏了纽约市最近的一个“180度大转弯”，我才有理由把它放给你们听。
So a couple weeks ago, the city of New York said that it was considering lifting its longtime band on ferrets as pets.
几周前，纽约市政府表示正在考虑取消长期以来对雪貂作为宠物的禁令。
[PAPERS RUSTLING]
[纸张沙沙声]
[CLEARS THROAT] I'm holding the Department of Health memo on the subject here. It was obtained by The New York Times recently. "Decision memo-- ferrets. Purpose-- allow ferrets to be kept as pets with restrictions." The memo goes on to discuss the history of the ferret ban, how it started under former Mayor Rudy Giuliani, how it came about because of, quote, "reports in the literature" of ferret attacks on young babies.
[清嗓子] 我手里拿着卫生局关于此事的备忘录，这是《纽约时报》最近获取的。“决定备忘录——雪貂。目的——允许在有限制的情况下将雪貂作为宠物饲养。”备忘录接着讨论了雪貂禁令的历史，它是如何在鲁迪·朱利安尼（Rudy Giuliani）前市长任内开始的，以及它是因为引用“文献报道”称雪貂会袭击婴儿而产生的。
And then it lists the reasons to lift the ban. Most other places, including New York state, do not ban ferrets. Ferrets aren't anymore disease-prone than dogs or cats. And, quote, "evidence shows ferrets do not bite more frequently or severely than pets of the same size." Ferrets, in other words, are being unfairly singled out.
接着，它列出了取消禁令的理由。大多数其他地方，包括纽约州，并不禁止雪貂。雪貂并不比猫狗更容易携带疾病。而且，引用“证据表明雪貂咬人的频率或严重程度并不比同等体型的宠物高。”换句话说，雪貂受到了不公平的针对。
And then down at the very bottom, there are these couple of lines where it discusses what the reaction might be if the ferret ban is lifted. It says, quote, "There was a well-known exchange between Mayor Giuliani and a ferret advocate." The city should, quote, "expect the past to be reprised." Past, reprise yourself.
在底部，有几行字讨论了如果取消雪貂禁令可能会产生的反应。它说，引用“朱利安尼市长和一位雪貂倡导者之间曾有过一次著名的交锋。”市政府应该，引用“预期历史重演”。历史啊，你自己重演吧。
We're going to go to David in Oceanside.
我们要连线海洋城的戴维。
Hello, Mr. Giuliani. We speak again.
你好，朱利安尼先生。我们又说话了。
Hi, David.
你好，戴维。
Uh--
呃——
The set-up here-- it's the summer of 1999. Mayor Giuliani back then had a call-in radio show that he would host. And the caller on the line is David Guthartz, executive president of an organization called New York Ferret's Rights Advocacy.
背景是——那是1999年的夏天。当时的朱利安尼市长有一个他主持的电台直播节目。连线的听众是“纽约雪貂权利倡导组织”的执行主席戴维·古萨茨（David Guthartz）。
Let me introduce myself again. David Guthartz, executive president of New York Ferret's Rights Advocacy. Last week, when we spoke--
让我再介绍一下自己。戴维·古萨茨，纽约雪貂权利倡导组织的执行主席。上周我们通话时——
Oh, no.
哦，不。
--you said a very disparaging remark to me that I should get a life. That was very unprofessional of you. Here we're trying to get something--
——你对我说了一句非常贬损的话，说我该去找点正事做。你那样做非常不专业。我们在这里正试图让某件事——
I--
我——
--seriously done. Without you talking over me, we're trying to get something very seriously done.
——认真地完成。在你别打断我的情况下，我们正试图认真完成某件事。
David, you're on my show. I have the right to talk over you.
戴维，你是在我的节目里。我有权打断你。
But here's the thing--
但重点是——
And the fact is--
事实是——
--you talked over me  the last time.
——你上次也打断了我。
And the fact--
事实是——
And we are trying to get--
我们正试图——
And the fact-- David!
事实是——戴维！
--an important issue taken care of, where the city is violating state law.
——解决一个重要的问题，市政府正在违反州法律。
Get-- David.
得了吧——戴维。
And I asked you last week if you care about the law.
我上周问过你，你是否关心法律。
Yes, I do care about the law.
是的，我关心法律。
So why are you--
那你为什么——
I think you have totally and absolutely misinterpreted the law, because there's something deranged about you.
我认为你完全彻底地曲解了法律，因为你有点精神错乱。
No, there isn't!
不，我没有！
They go back and forth like this for quite a while, until finally Mayor Giuliani hangs up on David, but then keeps on talking.
他们就这样来来回回争论了很久，直到朱利安尼市长最终挂断了戴维的电话，但随后继续说着。
--serious. There is--
——严肃的。有——
Mr. Giuliani.
朱利安尼先生。
David.
戴维。
Rudy.
鲁迪。
This conversation is over, David. Thank you. There is something really, really very sad about you. You need help. This excessive concern with little weasels is a sickness. I'm sorry. That's my opinion.
谈话结束了，戴维。谢谢。你身上确实有些非常、非常令人悲哀的东西。你需要帮助。这种对小鼬类的过度关注是一种病。我很抱歉。这是我的观点。
You don't have to accept it. There are probably very few people who would be as honest with you about that. But you should go consult a psychologist or a psychiatrist and have him help you with this excessive concern, how you are devoting your life to weasels. You have a sickness.
你不必接受。可能很少有人会在这件事上对你如此诚实。但你应该去咨询心理学家或精神科医生，让他们帮你解决这种过度关注的问题，你把自己的一生都献给了鼬类。你有病。
And I know it's hard for you to accept that, because you hang on to this sickness. And it's your shield. It's your whatever. And I know you're real angry at me, and you're going to attack me. But actually, you're angry at yourself. So, David, see what you can do to get help.
我知道你很难接受这一点，因为你执着于这种病态。这是你的盾牌，或是别的什么。我知道你对我真的很生气，你会攻击我。但实际上，你是在对自己生气。所以，戴维，看看你能做些什么来寻求帮助。
Now we're going to move on to Richard in the Bronx.
现在我们转向布朗克斯区的理查德。
Hello?
喂？
Yes, Richard.
是的，理查德。
Yes. Mr. Mayor, my name is Richard--
是的。市长先生，我叫理查德——
Whoa.
哇。
That's Little Girl.
那是“小女孩”（Little Girl）。
So what's-- who is this?
这是——这是谁？
This is Princess Stardust Serenade Ferret. That's her full name.
这是“星尘小夜曲雪貂公主”（Princess Stardust Serenade Ferret）。那是她的全名。
Wow.
哇。
This week, one of our producers, Brian Reed, caught up with David Guthartz, the ferret advocate in that exchange, at his home in Long Island. At times in his life, he's had up to five ferrets at once. There was Butch Cassidy, Thief of Hearts; Butch Cassidy, Thief of Hearts Junior; Linus van Pelt. But now, it's just the one-- Princess Stardust.
这周，我们的制作人布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）在长岛的家中采访了那次交锋中的雪貂倡导者戴维·古萨茨。他一生中曾同时养过五只雪貂。有“布奇·卡西迪，偷心贼”、“小布奇·卡西迪，偷心贼”、“莱纳斯·凡·佩尔特”。但现在，只有这一只——星尘公主。
And Brian was here because we wanted to hear David savor his victory. 15 years after that radio interview where he's berated by the nation's most powerful mayor, vindication is at hand. Ferrets may soon be legal in New York City.
布莱恩去那里是因为我们想听听戴维享受他的胜利。在那次被全美最有权势的市长斥责的电台采访过去15年后，昭雪时刻终于到来。雪貂可能很快就会在纽约市合法化。
But David Guthartz says the way these new rules being proposed would only make things worse. Sure, they lift the ban, but only if you have a license. State law, which allows ferrets and which David feels should trump city law anyway, doesn't require a license.
但戴维·古萨茨说，提议中的这些新规则只会让事情变得更糟。确实，他们取消了禁令，但前提是你得有执照。州法律允许养雪貂，而且戴维认为这本应凌驾于市法律之上，但州法律并不要求执照。
So if the city puts this in place, it's going contrary even more so to New York state law.
所以如果市政府推行这一套，反而更加背离纽约州法律了。
But you're still allowed to own ferrets. Like, that still sounds better to me than if you want to have a ferret, then having to break the law to do it.
但你仍然可以拥有雪貂。我觉得这总比如果你想养雪貂就必须违法来做要好得多。
No. Because if you going to do something, you do it right. Otherwise, don't do it.
不。因为如果你要做某事，就得做得正确。否则，就别做。
Brian and David went around and around on this. Brian saying, come on. This is worth at least a little bit of celebration, right? David's answer, always the same-- no.
布莱恩和戴维一直在争论这个问题。布莱恩说，拜托，这至少值得庆祝一下吧？戴维的回答始终如一——不。
I got to say, the theme of our show this week is "180." Like doing a 180, a complete turnaround or complete reversal. And I came to visit you, because our impression was that the city was doing a 180 on ferret policy. But from talking to you, it seems like you don't think it's a 180.
我得说，本周我们节目的主题是“180”。比如做一个180度大转弯，彻底的改变或反转。我来拜访你是因为我们的印象是市政府在雪貂政策上做了一个180度大转弯。但和你谈话后，看起来你并不觉得这是一个180度大转弯。
No, it's not a 180. It's more like a five-degree turn. [LAUGHS] It's a tiny, tiny step, when by right they should be taking a giant leap.
不，这不是180度。这更像是转了五度。[笑] 这只是迈出了一小步，而他们理应迈出一大步。
180s are hard to get right. They can be controversial, even to the people whose side you're joining. There's all that history that came before, when you were going in the other direction, fighting on the opposite side. It's hard for people to trust you now. Today on our show, 180s and the controversy they invariably cause.
180度转弯很难做到位。它们可能会引起争议，甚至对那些你刚刚加入的一方也是如此。在你转向之前，你曾朝着相反的方向走，在对立面战斗，那里面有太多的历史包袱。现在人们很难信任你。今天在我们的节目中，我们要聊聊180度大转弯以及它们不可避免地引发的争议。
Act One of our show, Seeing the Forest through the Little Trees, the story of a beloved classic of high school English, an infamous speech on racial hatred, and the 180 that unites them both. Act Two, Unsafety Exit, wherein a teenager, after consulting the many adults in  his life charged with keeping him safe, takes all their advice and decides that the one rational act to take is to put himself in danger. Act Three, "I'm the One who Knocks," a short story by Ben Loory about the 180 we're all hoping for. Stay with us.
本节目的第一部分，“透过小树看森林”，讲述了一本深受高中生喜爱的高中英语经典读物，一段臭名昭著的关于种族仇恨的演讲，以及将二者联系在一起的180度大转弯。第二部分，“不安全出口”，讲述了一名青少年在咨询了生活中负责保护他的多位成年人后，听从了他们的所有建议，决定采取的最理性的行动是将自己置于危险之中。第三部分，“我是那个敲门的人”，由本·卢里（Ben Loory）创作的短篇小说，讲述了我们都期待的180度大转弯。请继续收听。
Act One, Seeing the Forest for the Little Trees. I'm going to start this story here, in the halls of Masconomet Regional High School in Topsfield, Massachusetts. The story will eventually take us many other places from Alabama to Texas to New York and Hollywood. But we're starting here, just outside Thomas Trevenen's sophomore English class.
第一部分，透过小树看森林。我将从马萨诸塞州托普斯菲尔德的马斯科内梅特地区高中的走廊里开始这个故事。这个故事最终会带我们去往许多其他地方，从阿拉巴马州到得克萨斯州，再到纽约和好莱坞。但我们先从托马斯·特雷文南（Thomas Trevenen）的二年级英语课外开始。
The students are about to discuss a book that's read in a lot of high schools just like this one all across the country, a book that's at the center of our story-- The Education of Little Tree .
学生们即将讨论一本书，这本书在全国各地的许多高中都有阅读，它是我们故事的核心——《小树的教育》（The Education of Little Tree）。
OK, so The Education of Little Tree is about this boy named Little Tree.
好的，《小树的教育》讲的是一个名叫“小树”的男孩。
This is a 16-year-old in the class named Mana.
这是一位班上16岁名叫玛娜（Mana）的学生。
So his parents die when he's five, like, both his mother and his father. And he goes to live with his Cherokeean grandparents.
他的父母在他五岁时去世了，他的母亲和父亲都去世了。然后他去和他的切诺基族祖父母住在一起。
The Education of Little Tree was first published in the mid-1970s as an autobiography of the book's author Forrest Carter. It's been a staple of high school English and history classes for decades. Little Tree's grandparents teach him to respect the earth, to take only what he needs from nature, and to appreciate the fundamental human virtues of respect and tolerance.
《小树的教育》最初出版于70年代中期，作为书作者福雷斯特·卡特（Forrest Carter）的自传。几十年来，它一直是高中英语和历史课的必修读物。小树的祖父母教导他尊重地球，只从自然中获取他所需要的，并领悟尊重和宽容的基本人类美德。
Here's another student, Joseph, who's 16.
这是另一位16岁的学生约瑟夫（Joseph）。
He was learning to deal with racial discrimination and prejudice and try and expand his understanding of the world and nature. And I'm trying to do that, too.
他正在学习处理种族歧视和偏见，并试图扩展他对世界和自然的理解。我也在尝试这样做。
And this book? It's a hit.
而这本书呢？它很受欢迎。
This is kind of embarrassing. But near the end, I really-- I sort of found myself getting a little emotional. But I really liked it. I found that I really connected to Little Tree. I felt like he was a lot like me. Sort of I'm on the same journey that he was.
这有点尴尬。但在快结束时，我真的……我发现自己变得有点情绪化。但我真的很喜欢它。我发现我真的与小树产生了共鸣。我觉得他很像我。就像我正在经历和他一样的旅程。
We're both trying to become better people. I'm trying to learn to be a good person, become who I am, be a man. But so was Little Tree.
我们都在努力成为更好的人。我正在学习做一个好人，成为我自己，成为一个男人。小树也是如此。
There's one more thing we should say about The Education of Little Tree, something many people may already be aware of. It's a lie. It's not an autobiography. It's all made up.
关于《小树的教育》，我们还需要说一件事，许多人可能已经知道了。这是一个谎言。它不是自传。它是编造的。
And the fact that it's one of the larger literary hoaxes in history is discussed in some of the high schools where the book is taught, like this one. But in many others, it's not. And the true tale of how this book came to be contains some even more memorable characters learning somewhat darker lessons.
事实上，它是历史上最大的文学骗局之一，这一点在一些教授这本书的高中里会被讨论，比如这所学校。但在其他许多学校里，则不会。而这本书如何产生的真实故事包含了一些更令人难忘的角色，他们学习着某种更黑暗的教训。
Once you know this true story behind the book, it's hard to believe that it could have the kind of impact, convey the kind of message that it does to the students who read it today. Here to tell this larger story around the book is radio producer Joe Richman, who runs Radio Diaries . One more thing to mention-- there's some potentially offensive language about midway through this story. OK, Joe Richman, take it away.
一旦你了解了这本书背后的真实故事，就很难相信它今天还能对学生产生那样的影响，传达那样的信息。为我们讲述这个围绕这本书的更大故事的是广播制作人乔·里奇曼（Joe Richman），他是“广播日记”（Radio Diaries）的负责人。还有一件事要提——在这个故事的中段有一些潜在的冒犯性语言。好的，乔·里奇曼，开始吧。
The story behind The Education of Little Tree, this iconic book with a message of tolerance and respect, begins with the most famous racist political speech in American history.
《小树的教育》背后的故事，这本标志着宽容与尊重主题的偶像级读物，始于美国历史上最著名的种族主义政治演讲。
Thank you, ladies and gentleman. This is the inaugurate day of my inauguration as governor of the state of Alabama. And this day--
谢谢，女士们先生们。这是我作为阿拉巴马州州长的就职之日。在这一天——
During the Civil Rights era, George Wallace, the governor of Alabama, was the personification of Southern racism. He was the one who famously stood in the schoolhouse door to prevent two black students from enrolling at the University of Alabama. But the moment that first really catapulted Wallace onto the national stage was his inauguration speech in 1963.
在民权时代，阿拉巴马州州长乔治·华莱士（George Wallace）是南方种族主义的化身。他就是那个因站在校门口阻止两名黑人学生进入阿拉巴马大学而闻名的人。但真正让华莱士登上国家舞台的时刻，是他1963年的就职演说。
Let us send this message back to Washington that from this day we are standing up and the heel of tyranny does not fit the neck of an upright man.
让我们把这条信息传回华盛顿：从今天起，我们站起来了，暴政的铁蹄不再适合正直之人的脖颈。
He was promising that he was going to stand alone for the Southern cause, the cause of the white people.
他承诺他将为南方事业，即白人的事业，孤军奋战。
Wayne Greenhaw was a young reporter in Alabama in the 1960s. He remembers listening to this speech and the famous words "segregation now, segregation tomorrow, segregation forever."
韦恩·格林豪（Wayne Greenhaw）是1960年代阿拉巴马州的一名年轻记者。他记得听过那次演讲，还有那句名言：“种族隔离在现在，种族隔离在明天，种族隔离永远。”
It's vehement, it's mean-spirited, it's hateful. It's like a rattlesnake was hissing it almost. But it's beautifully written.
那充满了愤怒，心胸狭隘，充满了仇恨。就像响尾蛇在嘶嘶作响。但它写得非常优美。
In the name of the greatest people that have ever trod this earth, I draw the line in the dust and toss the gauntlet before the feet of tyranny. And I say segregation now, segregation tomorrow, and segregation forever.
以这片大地上曾经行走过的最伟大人民的名义，我在尘埃中画了一条线，把挑战抛在暴政的脚下。我说：种族隔离在现在，种族隔离在明天，种族隔离永远。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
This speech was a catalyst for much of the violence that followed. Just a few weeks later, Birmingham police used dogs and fire hoses on protesters. And later that same year, there was the bombing of a church in Birmingham, where four little girls were killed on a Sunday morning.
这次演讲是随后许多暴力事件的催化剂。就在几周后，伯明翰警方对抗议者使用了警犬和消防水龙。同年晚些时候，伯明翰的一座教堂发生了爆炸案，四个小女孩在周日早晨被杀害。
Today what most Americans know about George Wallace are those words-- "segregation now, segregation forever" --even though they weren't actually his words. Behind those words, behind that speech was an entirely different person-- Asa Carter, the poet laureate of Southern racist speech writing.
今天大多数美国人所知道的关于乔治·华莱士的事就是那些话——“种族隔离在现在，种族隔离永远”——尽管那实际上并不是他的话。在这些话语背后，在那个演讲背后，是完全不同的人——阿萨·卡特（Asa Carter），南方种族主义演讲词的桂冠诗人。
"Segregation now, segregation forever" became Wallace's symbol. It all came from Asa Carter's pen. And nobody could write it any better than Asa.
“种族隔离在现在，种族隔离永远”成了华莱士的象征。这一切都出自阿萨·卡特的笔下。没有人能比阿萨写得更好。
It's time for another essay on liberty by Asa Carter.
又是阿萨·卡特自由演讲时间了。
Thank you. The one great truth is race. Each race has a character, and each race--
谢谢。唯一的真理是种族。每个种族都有自己的性格，每个种族——
That's Asa Carter. He was a staunch segregationist. He started his own splinter branch of the KKK in Alabama. He wrote and published a white supremacist magazine. And every week, radio stations around Alabama would air Asa Carter's 15-minute liberty essays, which were about everything from his views on racial purity to the dangers of integration, communism, and rock and roll, all delivered with literary flair.
那就是阿萨·卡特。他是一个坚定的种族隔离主义者。他在阿拉巴马州创立了自己的三K党分支。他撰写并出版了一本白人至上主义杂志。每周，阿拉巴马州各地的电台都会播放阿萨·卡特15分钟的自由演讲，内容涵盖他对比种族纯洁性的看法，到反对融合、共产主义和摇滚乐的危险，所有演讲都带着文学色彩。
That's why the left-winger so much wants to make our history a shrouded nothingness of confusion, to twist the songs of our fathers into bebop rhythms, and to degenerate our mores into a cacophony of chaos.
这就是为什么那些左翼分子如此渴望将我们的历史变成一片混乱的虚无，将我们先辈的歌声扭曲成波普节奏，并将我们的习俗沦落为一片混沌的嘈杂。
You've been listening to Asa Carter with an essay on liberty.
你收听到的是阿萨·卡特关于自由的演讲。
In 1956, Asa had his KKK group attack singer Nat King Cole on stage, because Asa hated the idea that a black musician was performing for white women. Asa reserved special hatred for the Jews, who he felt were really to blame for the corrupting power of popular culture. He once said, "The Negro is the virus, but it's the Jew that inserts it in the veins of America."
1956年，阿萨让他的三K党成员在舞台上袭击了歌手纳特·金·科尔（Nat King Cole），因为阿萨痛恨黑人音乐家为白人女性表演的想法。阿萨对犹太人怀有特殊的仇恨，他认为流行文化的腐蚀力量真正要归咎于他们。他曾经说：“黑人是病毒，但正是犹太人把它注入了美国的血管。”
And then in 1962, Asa got a new gig as George Wallace's speechwriter Ron Taylor was a good friend of Asa Carter's.
到了1962年，阿萨得到了担任乔治·华莱士演讲撰稿人的新工作。罗恩·泰勒（Ron Taylor）是阿萨·卡特的好朋友。
They'd call him and tell him what they wanted, you know. And they'd just give him a cup of coffee and two packs of Pall Malls, and he could write you a 20-minute speech in 30 minutes.
他们会给他打电话，告诉他他们想要什么。他们只需给他一杯咖啡和两包Pall Mall香烟，他就能在30分钟内给你写出一篇20分钟的演讲。
Asa's speeches helped George Wallace become governor in 1962. But within a few years, the arrangement was falling apart. Tom Turnipseed was George Wallace's campaign director back then.
阿萨的演讲帮助乔治·华莱士在1962年当选州长。但几年之内，这种合作就开始瓦解了。汤姆·特尼西德（Tom Turnipseed）当时是乔治·华莱士的竞选总监。
Times changed, and Wallace wanted to cool it a little bit. He didn't want to just come out and say, I'm a segregationist. He didn't want to use that terminology anymore. He wanted to be more moderate.
时代变了，华莱士想稍微降降温。他不想再直接跳出来说，我是个种族隔离主义者。他不想再使用那样的术语了。他想变得更温和一些。
Asa's views were too extreme. And so Gov. Wallace didn't need Asa anymore. Asa would call me up and talk with me on the phone some. And he was resentful because he just felt like he was being ignored.
阿萨的观点太极端了。所以华莱士州长不再需要阿萨了。阿萨会给我打电话，我们聊上一些。他感到愤恨，因为他觉得被冷落了。
Here's the guy that wrote the famous, iconic speech. And now Wallace, he won't listen to me anymore. He won't talk with me. He won't take my advice. And so he felt used, I think, by Gov. Wallace.
这就是那个写出著名标志性演讲的人。现在华莱士不再听他的了。他不再跟他说话，不再采纳他的建议。所以我想，他觉得自己被华莱士州长利用了。
--upon which I am about to enter to the best of my ability, to the best of my ability--
——我即将以我的最佳能力，以我的最佳能力进入这个职位——
George Wallace was elected governor again in 1970. But this time, his inauguration speech was very different from the speech that Asa Carter had written back in 1963. Wallace said, "Alabama belongs to all of us, black and white, young and old, rich and poor alike."
乔治·华莱士在1970年再次当选州长。但这一次，他的就职演说与阿萨·卡特在1963年写的演讲大不相同。华莱士说：“阿拉巴马属于我们所有人，黑人和白人，年轻人和老年人，富人和穷人。”
Reporter Wayne Greenhaw was on the steps of the capital at the time covering Wallace's inauguration address. And he happened to run into Asa Carter.
记者韦恩·格林豪当时在州议会大厦的台阶上报道华莱士的就职演说。他碰巧遇见了阿萨·卡特。
After the speech, I found Asa out on the back steps of the capitol. And we sat on the stairs, talking. And he started crying. He said, "Wayne, George Wallace sold out. He's betraying us to the liberals of this nation." He stood up and turned around and said farewell.
演讲结束后，我在议会大厦的后台阶上发现了阿萨。我们坐在楼梯上聊天。他开始哭。他说：“韦恩，乔治·华莱士出卖了我们。他正在把我们出卖给国家的自由派。”他站起来转过身说再见。
Well, I am just an old rebel, I reckon that is all I am. For this carpetbagger government, I do not give a dadblame. I'm glad I fit again'it. I'll keep fighting until we won. And I don't want to pardon for nothing that I've done.
好吧，我不过是个老叛逆，我想就是这样。对于这个地毯包客政府，我一点也不在乎。我很高兴我反抗了。我会继续战斗直到胜利。而且我对自己所做的一切不寻求任何宽恕。
This is Asa Carter. May God bless you. And I thank you for listening.
这是阿萨·卡特。愿上帝保佑你。谢谢你的聆听。
And that's the last time I ever saw Asa Carter. He just vanished like he dropped off the face of the earth.
那是我最后一次见到阿萨·卡特。他就那样消失了，就像从地球表面掉下去了一样。
My name is Chuck Weeth.
我叫查克·威斯（Chuck Weeth）。
I'm Betty Weeth.
我是贝蒂·威斯（Betty Weeth）。
And I and my wife ran a bookstore in our town of Abilene, Texas. In 1975, this man came walking in the store and said, "I'd like to introduce myself. I'm Forrest Carter."
我和我妻子在得克萨斯州的阿比林镇经营一家书店。1975年，这个男人走进店里说：“我想自我介绍一下。我是福雷斯特·卡特（Forrest Carter）。”
He wore a cowboy hat, blue jeans, and had a mustache.
他戴着牛仔帽，穿着蓝色牛仔裤，留着小胡子。
He's dark complected, smile wrinkles around his eyes. He said he was Cherokee and he was raised by his grandparents back in Tennessee. No electricity, no running water. And I liked him. From the very start, I liked him.
他皮肤黝黑，眼睛周围有笑纹。他说他是切诺基人，由他在田纳西州的祖父母抚养长大。没有电，没有自来水。我喜欢他。从一开始，我就喜欢他。
This new guy in town, Forrest Carter, quickly became a fixture in Abilene, Texas. Chuck and Betty Weeth say Forrest was outgoing and friendly. He told people in town he never had any formal education and spent his adult life wandering between ranch jobs. And he entertained everybody with stories about his Cherokee childhood.
这个镇上的新面孔，福雷斯特·卡特，很快成了得克萨斯州阿比林的常客。查克和贝蒂·威斯说福雷斯特性格外向友好。他告诉镇上的人他从未受过正规教育，成年后一直在各地的牧场工作之间漂泊。他用关于他切诺基童年的故事招待大家。
We had him to our house several times for supper, just because you wanted to hear a little more about this life, which I wasn't familiar with at all.
我们多次请他到家里吃晚饭，只是因为你想多听听那种我不熟悉的生活。
He was sort of the underdog of the American culture, and you were cheering for him. And you just grew to love him.
他像是美国文化中的失败者，而你却在为他喝彩。你只是不由自主地爱上了他。
Chuck and Betty Weeth knew Forrest was a writer and that he'd written a Western. Forrest told them he was sending copies of the book to people in Hollywood.
查克和贝蒂·威斯知道福雷斯特是一位作家，而且他写过一本西部小说。福雷斯特告诉他们他正在把书的副本寄给好莱坞的人。
He'd already approached--
他已经接触了——
Clint East--
克林特·伊斯特——
--Clint Eastwood. And lo and behold, Clint Eastwood was well enough taken by this first book, Forrest told us, he's planing to make a movie of it, which indeed he did do, called The Rebel Outlaw-- Josey Wales .
——克林特·伊斯特伍德（Clint Eastwood）。结果呢，正如福雷斯特告诉我们的，克林特·伊斯特伍德对这第一本书非常看重，他打算把它拍成电影，他确实也做了，名字叫《法外之徒：乔西·威尔斯》（The Rebel Outlaw - Josey Wales）。
He lives by his word. And he lives for revenge. Clint Eastwood is the outlaw Josey Wales.
他言出必行，他为复仇而活。克林特·伊斯特伍德就是法外之徒乔西·威尔斯。
Why, you gonna pull those pistols or whistle Dixie?
喂，你是要掏枪还是吹口哨？
During the time all this was happening, Forrest was hard at work on another book, a book he described differently than his first one. That was a novel. This was an autobiography. And he was calling it The Education of Little Tree . An orphan Cherokee boy raised by his grandparents who grows up to write a Hollywood movie starring Clint Eastwood-- it was made for TV.
在这期间，福雷斯特正在辛苦创作另一本书，一本书，他描述的方式与第一本不同。那是一部小说。而这本是自传。他把它命名为《小树的教育》。一个由祖父母抚养长大的切诺基孤儿，长大后写了一部由克林特·伊斯特伍德主演的好莱坞电影——这是为电视制作的。
Good morning. This is Today. I'm Barbara Walters with Jim Hartz.
早上好。这是《今天》（Today）节目。我是芭芭拉·沃尔特斯（Barbara Walters），和吉姆·哈茨（Jim Hartz）一起。
And in fact, in 1975, Forrest was invited to New York to be a guest on The Today Show with Barbara Walters.
事实上，1975年，福雷斯特被邀请到纽约，作为嘉宾参加芭芭拉·沃尔特斯的《今天》节目。
She introduced him as an Indian who had busted broncos all over the Southwest.
她介绍他是一位在整个美国西南部驯服野马的印第安人。
While viewers around the country were being introduced to Forrest Carter, there were some people back in Alabama who recognized a man they hadn't seen in years. Ron Taylor remembers watching that morning as Forrest Carter told viewers he was the storyteller to the Cherokee Nation.
当全国观众都在认识福雷斯特·卡特时，阿拉巴马州有一些人认出了一个他们多年没见过的人。罗恩·泰勒记得那天早上看电视时，福雷斯特·卡特告诉观众他是切诺基民族的说书人。
He had that black hat pulled way down. [LAUGHS] He just tanned himself up, grew a mustache, lost about 20 pound. But as hard as he tried, he couldn't fool the folks back home. I literally got down on the floor laughing and rolling around. Call the wife, "Asa's on TV! He's on with Barbara Walters." And I'm just rolling around on the floor laughing because Asa had pulled it, you know. He had fooled them.
他把那顶黑帽子压得很低。[笑] 他只是把自己晒黑了，留了胡子，瘦了大约20磅。但不管他怎么努力，他也骗不了老家的人。我当时简直笑得在地板上打滚。我叫我老婆说：“阿萨在电视上！他正和芭芭拉·沃尔特斯在一起。”我当时笑得在地板上打滚，因为阿萨得逞了，你知道吗。他骗过了他们。
By the time The Today Show aired around the country, reporter Wayne Greenhaw had already been onto the story for a few months, the story that Asa Carter and Forrest Carter seemed to be the same person. The tip-off came when Wayne happened to write a review of Forrest Carter's first book, the one that became a movie. After the book review appeared in the paper, Wayne ran into an old friend of Asa Carter's, Ray Andrews.
在《今天》节目全国播出时，记者韦恩·格林豪已经跟进这个故事几个月了，关于阿萨·卡特和福雷斯特·卡特似乎是同一个人的故事。线索来自于韦恩碰巧为福雷斯特·卡特的第一本书写了一篇书评，就是后来拍成电影的那本。书评在报纸上刊登后，韦恩偶然遇到了阿萨·卡特的老朋友雷·安德鲁斯（Ray Andrews）。
And Ray said, "Old Asa's got you fooled too, huh?" And I said, "What are you talking about?" And he said, "I saw you wrote a review of Asa's novel." I said, "That's Forrest Carter."
雷说：“老阿萨也把你骗了，是吧？”我说：“你在说什么？”他说：“我看到你写了一篇阿萨小说的书评。”我说：“那是福雷斯特·卡特。”
And Ray grinned and laughed and said, "Yeah, that's old Asa. Asa's Forrest Carter." Well, I thought, what in the world? And it just bumfuzzled me.
雷咧嘴一笑，笑出声来说：“是啊，那是老阿萨。阿萨就是福雷斯特·卡特。”好吧，我想，这到底是怎么回事？我完全被搞糊涂了。
After that original bumfuzzle, Wayne started to make calls.
在最初的困惑之后，韦恩开始打电话。
I got in contact with Eleanor Friede, who was a editor at Delacorte Press. And she had discovered Forrest Carter. And when I told her the story, she said, "Oh, no. It couldn't be the same guy. He's such a sweet, gentle, fine man. He would never say a word about anybody because of the color of their skin. And I know he's not anti-Semitic, because my husband and I are Jewish, and we've had him to dinner a number of times. And he's always just as nice as he could be. It just couldn't be the same man."
我联系了德拉科特出版社（Delacorte Press）的编辑埃莉诺·弗里德（Eleanor Friede）。她是福雷斯特·卡特的发现者。当我告诉她这个故事时，她说：“噢，不。不可能是一个人。他是一个如此甜美、温柔、优秀的人。他绝不会因为皮肤颜色而对任何人说三道四。而且我知道他不反犹太人，因为我和我丈夫是犹太人，我们多次请他吃晚饭。他总是非常友善。绝不可能是同一个人。”
In fact, the editor told Wayne she was about to publish Forrest Carter's autobiography, The Education of Little Tree . Wayne told her he would still love to talk to Forrest Carter himself, because he was writing a story for The New York Times about all this.
事实上，编辑告诉韦恩，她正准备出版福雷斯特·卡特的自传《小树的教育》。韦恩告诉她，他仍然想和福雷斯特·卡特本人谈谈，因为他正在为《纽约时报》写一篇关于这一切的文章。
Sure enough, in a few days, Forrest Carter called me. And he said, "You're this Greenhaw writing about me." And I said, "Yes, sir." And he said, "Now, you don't want to hurt old Forrest, do you, boy?" And I said, "Come off of it, Asa. I recognize that voice. I know you, you know me. We've drunk beer together."
果然，几天后，福雷斯特·卡特打给我。他说：“你就是写关于我的那个格林豪吗？”我说：“是的，先生。”他说：“现在，你不想伤害老福雷斯特，对吧，小伙子？”我说：“别装了，阿萨。我认得那个声音。我认识你，你也认识我。我们一起喝过啤酒。”
I said, "I'm not trying to hurt you, but this business of Little Tree is not a true story." I said, "I want to tell the truth about what is going on here." He said, "Oh, boy, you know I don't do things like that." And he pretty much after that hung up.
我说：“我不是要伤害你，但《小树》这回事并不是一个真实的故事。”我说：“我想说出这里正在发生的事情的真相。”他说：“噢，孩子，你知道我不会做那种事。”说完他基本就挂了。
Wayne had no idea why Asa was doing what he was doing. Why had he changed his name and become a storyteller to the Cherokee Nation? Why had he gotten a tan, slimmed down, and grown a mustache? And how did he expect to get away with going on TV and talking to Barbara Walters in a fake Texas accent?
韦恩不知道阿萨为什么要这么做。他为什么要改名并成为切诺基民族的说书人？他为什么要晒黑、减肥并留胡子？他怎么指望能骗过芭芭拉·沃尔特斯并操着假得克萨斯口音上电视？
All Wayne knew was Forrest Carter was lying. He wasn't a Cherokee. This wasn't a memoir. And his name wasn't Forrest.
韦恩只知道福雷斯特·卡特在撒谎。他不是切诺基人。这也不是回忆录。他的名字也不是福雷斯特。
And the story ran in The New York Times August the 26th of 1976 with the headline, "Is Forrest Carter really Asa Carter? Only Josey Wales may know for sure."
这个故事发表在1976年8月26日的《纽约时报》上，标题是：“福雷斯特·卡特真的是阿萨·卡特吗？只有乔西·威尔斯可能确定。”
Wayne though his New York Times article was going to set off a huge scandal. But a curious thing happened after the article came out, something that surprised Wayne Greenhaw. And it probably surprised Asa and Forrest Carter. What happened was nothing.
韦恩以为他的《纽约时报》文章会引发巨大的丑闻。但文章发表后发生了一件奇怪的事情，一些让韦恩·格林豪感到惊讶的事情。这可能也让阿萨/福雷斯特·卡特感到惊讶。发生的事情是：什么都没发生。
A few months later, Forrest Carter's autobiography, The Education of Little Tree , was published. And in fact, after Forest slash Asa died in 1979, the book just became more and more popular. In the late 1980s, The Education of Little Tree caught a wave of rising interest in all things Native American. And people seemed to identify with its themes-- humility, tolerance, living in harmony with nature.
几个月后，福雷斯特·卡特的自传《小树的教育》出版了。事实上，在福雷斯特/阿萨于1979年去世后，这本书变得越来越受欢迎。1980年代末，《小树的教育》掀起了一股对所有美洲原住民事物的热潮。人们似乎认同书中的主题——谦逊、宽容、与自然和谐共处。
A new paperback edition included a foreword by an actual Cherokee writer who called the book deeply poignant and compared it to Huck Finn. More than a million copies were sold. In 1991, the book reached number one on The New York Times Nonfiction Best Seller List. In 1994, Oprah Winfrey recommended it on her TV show.
一本新的平装本包含了由一位真正的切诺基作家所写的序言，他称这本书极其感人，并将其与《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》相提并论。它卖出了超过一百万册。1991年，该书在《纽约时报》非虚构类畅销书榜上排名第一。1994年，奥普拉·温弗瑞（Oprah Winfrey）在她的电视节目中推荐了它。
Every once in a while, a new article would come out revealing yet again the racist past of the book's author, and some small things would change. The New York Times moved the book from the nonfiction to fiction category. Oprah eventually took it off her book list. Some Native Americans said the book was full of stereotypes and was a complete fraud, but the Cherokee guy who wrote the foreword stood by it. It seemed that no matter what came out about the background of the book, its popularity continued. Today you can find it in Barnes & Noble in the Native American section.
每隔一段时间，就会有一篇新文章出来，再次揭露书作者的种族主义过去，一些小事会发生变化。比如《纽约时报》将这本书从非虚构类调整为虚构类。奥普拉最终将其从书单中删除。一些美洲原住民说这本书充满了刻板印象，完全是骗局，但写序言的那位切诺基人坚持力挺它。似乎无论关于书的背景爆出什么，它的受欢迎程度都在持续。今天你可以在巴诺书店的“美洲原住民”区域找到它。
Most people who loved the book simply could not imagine that a former Klansman, racist, anti-Semite, this person couldn't have written The Education of Little Tree .
大多数喜欢这本书的人简直无法想象，一个前三K党成员、种族主义者、反犹太主义者，竟然能写出《小树的教育》。
This is historian Dan Carter, who, by the way, isn't related to Asa Carter. But he is writing a biography of the man. And he hits on the question that's at the center of the whole story. Is it possible that something happened in the heart of Asa Carter? Did he change? Was he a reformed racist trying to break from his shameful past? Or was he just trying to make a buck? Or was it all just a joke on his new-age liberal readers?
这是历史学家丹·卡特（Dan Carter），顺便说一句，他与阿萨·卡特没有任何亲属关系。但他正在为这个人写传记。他触及了整个故事核心的问题。阿萨·卡特的心里是否真的发生了什么？他改变了吗？他是一个试图摆脱羞耻过去的改过自新的种族主义者吗？还是他只是想赚一笔钱？亦或是这只是他对新时代自由派读者开的一个玩笑？
What does it mean that the man who wrote this--
一个写出这样东西的人意味着什么——
And I say segregation now, segregation tomorrow, and segregation forever.
我说：种族隔离在现在，种族隔离在明天，种族隔离永远。
--could also write this?
——也能写出这样东西吗？
One time grandma told me, when you come on something good, first thing to do is share it with whosoever you can find. That way the good spreads out where no telling how far it'll go.
有一次祖母告诉我，当你遇到好东西时，第一件事就是与你能找到的任何人分享。那样好东西就会传播开来，不知道能传多远。
Here's Asa Carter.
这是阿萨·卡特。
In the South, we have 98% Anglo-Saxon races, not counting the niggers.
在南方，我们有98%的盎格鲁-撒克逊种族，不算那些黑鬼（niggers）。
The only group Asa Carter hated more than blacks were Jews. So what does it mean that Forrest Carter created the character of Mr. Wine, a generous and sympathetic Jewish peddler who befriends Little Tree?
阿萨·卡特痛恨的群体中只有黑人比犹太人多。那么，福雷斯特·卡特创造了“温先生”（Mr. Wine）这个角色，一个慷慨、充满同情心且与小树结为好友的犹太小贩，这又意味着什么呢？
Mr. Wine said if you learn to place a value on being honest and thrifty, on doing your best, and on caring for folks, this was more important than anything.
温先生说，如果你学会重视诚实、节俭、尽力而为以及关心他人，这比什么都重要。
How could someone talk with so much venom--
一个人怎么能用如此恶毒的言语说话——
We shall submit to Negro dominion another day, another hour, another month. Behind every ballot is a bayonet and the red blood of an Anglo-Saxon who holds it.
我们将屈服于黑人的统治，又一天，又一小时，又一个月。在每一张选票背后，都是刺刀和拿着它的盎格鲁-撒克逊人的鲜血。
--and still write something so sweet?
——还能写出如此甜蜜的东西呢？
I could feel something more, as Grandma said I would. Mon-o-Lah, the Earth Mother, came to me through my moccasins. I would have liked to live that time forever, for I knew I had pleased Grandpa. I had learned the way.
我能感觉到更多，正如祖母所说的那样。大地母亲（Mon-o-Lah）通过我的鹿皮鞋向我走来。我本来希望永远活在那一刻，因为我知道我已经取悦了祖父。我已经学会了“方法”。
Actually, "the live in harmony with nature" message isn't really that surprising. You might expect a white supremacist to be nostalgic about living off the land. And someone can certainly write hate speech and still love nature. But what most leaders took from The Education of Little Tree is a message of tolerance and respect for Native Americans and for the African American and Jewish characters in the book. In fact, the villains in this story aren't the minorities. They're the white politicians.
事实上，“与自然和谐共处”的信息其实并不那么令人惊讶。你可能会期待一个白人至上主义者会对那种靠土地生活的生活方式感到怀旧。一个人当然可以写出仇恨言论同时仍然热爱自然。但大多数读者从《小树的教育》中得到的都是关于宽容和尊重美洲原住民，以及尊重书中非裔和犹太角色的信息。事实上，这个故事里的反派不是少数族裔。他们是白人政客。
For many people who love The Education of Little Tree , the only way to make sense of it was to take the book at its word and to believe that Asa Carter had truly changed. It wasn't an act, but a sincere transformation. Yes, OK, he wasn't a Cherokee orphan. But in this heart, he had become Forrest Carter. And Exhibit A for this point of view, for "the people can change and people do change" point of view, is Asa Carter's former boss George Wallace, the man he wrote speeches for.
对于许多喜欢《小树的教育》的人来说，理解它的唯一方式就是相信书中所言，并相信阿萨·卡特确实改变了。这不是演戏，而是真诚的转变。是的，好吧，他不是切诺基孤儿。但在他心里，他已经变成了福雷斯特·卡特。而支持这一观点，即“人们可以改变，人们确实会改变”这一观点的证据，就是阿萨·卡特的老板，乔治·华莱士。
Primary elections are being held Tuesday. And George Wallace is trying a come back, trying to become governor again.
初选将在周二举行。乔治·华莱士正在尝试东山再起，试图再次成为州长。
At black meetings, Wallace repudiates his former racist stance.
在黑人会议上，华莱士否定了他以前的种族主义立场。
And whether or not you agreed with me in everything that I used to do and agreed to, I know that you do not. I too see the mistakes that all of us made in years past.
无论你是否在过去我所做的一切事上都同意我的立场，我知道你不同意。我也看到了我们所有人过去几年犯下的错误。
This is footage from George Wallace's last campaign for governor in 1982. He was actually in a wheelchair-- the result of an assassination attempt. And he was in the midst of what would be known as his apology tour, going around the state to black churches and civic groups, anyone who would have him and saying, I was wrong.
这是乔治·华莱士1982年最后一次竞选州长的片段。他当时实际上坐在轮椅上——那是一次暗杀未遂的结果。他正处于后来被称为“道歉巡演”的中间，他走访该州的黑人教堂和公民团体，任何愿意见他的人，他说：我错了。
One of the civil rights leaders Wallace apologized to was Congressman John Lewis, who still has a visible scar on his head from famously being beaten by Alabama state troopers on the Edmund Pettus Bridge on the march to Selma, Alabama.
华莱士道歉的民权领袖之一是众议员约翰·刘易斯（John Lewis），他的头上至今留着明显的伤疤，因为他在著名的塞尔玛游行中被阿拉巴马州警在埃德蒙·佩特斯桥上殴打。
And I remember the occasion so well. It was like someone confessing to their priest or to a minister, just telling me everything and asking me about everybody, that he never had an opportunity to meet with Martin Luther King Junior, to meet Dr. King. He wanted people to forgive him. He said, "I never hated anybody. I never hated black people." He said, "Mr. Lewis, I'm sorry." And I said, "Well, Governor, I accept your apology."
我非常记得那个场合。就像某人向他的牧师忏悔一样，他告诉我一切，问我关于每个人的情况，说他从未有机会见到马丁·路德·金博士。他想要人们原谅他。他说：“我从不恨任何人。我从不恨黑人。”他说：“刘易斯先生，我很抱歉。”我说：“好吧，州长，我接受你的道歉。”
I believe people have the capacity to change. I think he was sincere.
我相信人有改变的能力。我认为他是真诚的。
George Wallace was a lifelong politician. And it's impossible to say if his change of heart was authentic or not. But the people he was apologizing to believed it. In his last election as governor of Alabama in 1982, he won with 90% of the black vote. Wallace continued his apology tours long after he left public office.
乔治·华莱士是一位终身政治家。无法断定他的悔改是真是假。但那些他道歉的人相信了。在他1982年最后一次竞选阿拉巴马州州长时，他赢得了90%的黑人选票。华莱士在他离开公共职位很久之后继续他的道歉之旅。
So George Wallace represents the transformation-is-possible theory. To people in Abilene, Texas, who are friends with Forrest Carter, the Cherokee writer, that's what happened to Asa Carter. He pulled a Wallace. Here's Chuck and Betty Weeth.
所以乔治·华莱士代表了“转变是有可能的”理论。对于得克萨斯州阿比林那些与福雷斯特·卡特——那位切诺基作家——是朋友的人来说，这就是阿萨·卡特所发生的事。他搞了一次“华莱士”。这是查克和贝蒂·威斯。
I personally think the Forrest Carter I knew was sincere. The other life he seemed to have had as Asa Carter, I just sort of dismiss it.
我个人认为我认识的那个福雷斯特·卡特是真诚的。他似乎作为阿萨·卡特所拥有的另一种生活，我只是将其摒弃。
I agree with that. I guess it's sort of that feeling that give a man a chance, he might change himself. And we felt like, well, he tried to change himself and he succeeded with us. I didn't like Asa Carter, I'll guarantee you. But I did like Forrest Carter.
我同意这一点。我猜这是一种“给一个人一个机会，他可能会改变自己”的感觉。我们觉得，好吧，他试图改变自己，并且他在我们身上成功了。我敢保证，我不喜欢阿萨·卡特。但我确实喜欢福雷斯特·卡特。
There's another person who has some thoughts on this, one of the few people who knew both Forrest and Asa Carter.
还有一个人对这件事有一些想法，他是为数不多既认识福雷斯特又认识阿萨·卡特的人之一。
He was Uncle Asa to me. He wasn't Uncle Asa, the white supremacist. He wasn't Uncle Asa, the staunch segregationist. He was Uncle Asa. So for me, it was my uncle wrote this wonderful book.
对我来说，他就是阿萨叔叔。他不是那个白人至上主义者的阿萨叔叔，不是那个坚定的种族隔离主义者的阿萨叔叔。他就是阿萨叔叔。所以对我来说，那是我的叔叔写的一本好书。
Carol Boyd is the daughter of Asa Carter's brother. She's never spoken about any of this on the record before. All of Asa's family members have kept silent for years. Like many of them, Carol was sheltered from most of the details of her uncle's racist past. The main thing she knew about her uncle-- he was the true author of The Education of Little Tree .
卡罗尔·博伊德（Carol Boyd）是阿萨·卡特哥哥的女儿。她之前从未公开谈论过这件事。阿萨的所有家庭成员多年来都保持沉默。像他们中的许多人一样，卡罗尔被屏蔽在她叔叔种族主义过去的细节之外。她对她叔叔了解的最主要的事情是——他是《小树的教育》的真实作者。
So when did you first read The Education of Little Tree ?
那你第一次读《小树的教育》是什么时候？
I guess I was a senior in high school when I first read it. I loved it. I fell in love with it. I actually cried. I just think it's a beautiful story. I still read it today.
我想我读高三的时候第一次读它。我喜欢它。我爱上了它。我实际上哭了。我只是觉得这是一个美丽的故事。我现在还在读它。
Carol describes herself as politically liberal. She voted for Obama twice. And to her, that book is all the proof she needs that in the end, her uncle wasn't so so different in his view from her.
卡罗尔形容自己是政治自由派。她给奥巴马投过两次票。对她来说，那本书就是她需要的全部证明，证明最终她叔叔在观点上和她并无太大差异。
Just to have the ability to write that book, whether you present it as an autobiography or not, just to have that in you I think says that there is a good part of this person. I would hope that people would choose to believe maybe he found a softer side in his older years. And maybe he did change.
仅仅拥有写那本书的能力，无论你是否把它当作自传呈现，仅仅拥有那种东西，我认为就说明这个人的身上是有好的一面的。我希望人们能选择相信，也许他在晚年找到了一种更柔和的一面。也许他真的改变了。
Did he change? That's the question you asked. No. No, no, no, no, no. Not at all. Not at all did he change.
他改变了吗？这就是你问的问题。没有。不，不，不，不，不。完全没有。他一点也没有改变。
This again is Ron Taylor, one of Asa Carter's friends from the early days back in Alabama. Ron would describe himself as the opposite of politically liberal. And he's chief proponent of theory number two--
这又是罗恩·泰勒（Ron Taylor），阿萨·卡特在阿拉巴马州早期的朋友之一。罗恩会把自己形容为政治自由派的对立面。他是“二号理论”的主要支持者——
No, no, no, no. No.
不，不，不，不。不。
--Asa Carter did not change.
——阿萨·卡特没有改变。
You know, I could do like some and just say, oh, he didn't really mean that. He didn't this, that, and the other, but did. He did. And to refute it, like say Wallace did and people like that, then that makes it their whole lives lies before. I mean, old Wallace, after they wheeled him out in his wheelchair, and he apologized for everything he ever was.
你知道，我可以像其他人一样说，噢，他不是那个意思。他不是这样那样，但他就是。他确实是。为了反驳这一点，像华莱士那样做，那让他们的整个人生都成了谎言。我是说，那个老华莱士，在他们把他推到轮椅上之后，他为他曾经所是的一切道歉。
But Asa Carter wasn't going to apologize. He felt like he was right. And he lived it and he died it. He just didn't change. He was Asa Carter.
但阿萨·卡特不会道歉。他觉得他是对的。他活在其中，也死在其中。他就是没有改变。他就是阿萨·卡特。
There are some interesting clues that support Ron's theory. Many of the supposed Cherokee words in the book Asa completely made up, just nonsense words. Mon-o-Lah, the Earth Mother, comes up a lot. Not a word. The name Forrest, it's not about communing with nature. It comes from Nathan Bedford Forrest. Never heard of him? He was the first Grand Wizard of the Ku Klux Klan.
有一些有趣的线索支持罗恩的理论。书中的许多所谓切诺基词汇都是阿萨完全编造的，纯粹是胡言乱语。“大地母亲”（Mon-o-Lah）出现了很多次。根本没这个词。福雷斯特（Forrest）这个名字，不是关于与自然交流。它来自内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特（Nathan Bedford Forrest）。没听说过他？他是三K党的第一任大巫师。
And even the fact that the book is told from the point of view of a Cherokee kid, some white supremacists, it turns out, had a thing for Native Americans. KKK members sometimes bragged about being part Native American. It's the noble savage trope that goes back to DW Griffith films and much earlier. It may seem counter-intuitive, but to Asa Carter, it was perfectly reasonable to glorify Native Americans while hating blacks and Jews.
甚至这本书是以一个切诺基孩子的视角讲述的这一点，事实证明，一些白人至上主义者确实对美洲原住民有一种迷恋。三K党成员有时会吹嘘自己有部分美洲原住民血统。这是那种可以追溯到DW格里菲斯电影以及更早之前的“高尚野蛮人”比喻。这看起来可能反直觉，但对阿萨·卡特来说，美化美洲原住民的同时仇恨黑人和犹太人是完全合理的。
And there's one more thing-- Asa's inscription in the copy of the book that he gave to Ron.
还有一件事——阿萨在他送给罗恩的那本书的扉页上的题词。
And this is my copy of it. It has gotten rather tattered. Here's signature page. It says "For Ronny, my friend whose loyalty to the Southern cause has made us comrades. Forrest 'Asa' end quote Carter." The only time he ever signed it that way.
这就是我那本。它已经很破旧了。这是签名页。它写着：“给罗尼，我的朋友，你对南方事业的忠诚使我们成为同志。福雷斯特‘阿萨’，引引引，卡特。”这是他唯一一次这样署名。
All this leads Ron to a third theory, one I wasn't expecting. Asa didn't change, and he didn't fake a change. The Education of Little Tree is exactly what Asa Carter always believed. Everyone else just misinterpreted it.
所有这一切都让罗恩得出了第三种理论，一种我没预料到的。阿萨没有改变，他也没有伪装改变。《小树的教育》正是阿萨·卡特始终相信的东西。其他人只是曲解了它。
Well, one way you look at it, it's a tree hugger's book. It's all about nature and this, that, and the other. And the other way it's a right-wing, "government, leave me alone" book. The government took Little Tree and put him in an orphanage, you see. And the government passed the whiskey tax. And the government did this. And the government did that to the American Indian. And that's the way I read it. I was shocked when I found out other people was understanding it differently.
嗯，如果你换个角度看，这是一本“拥抱树木者”的书。它全关于自然，诸如此类。而另一个角度看，它是一本右翼的“政府，别管我”的书。政府带走了小树并把他放在孤儿院，你瞧。政府通过了威士忌税。政府做了这个。政府对美洲印第安人做了那个。这就是我的解读方式。当我发现其他人理解得不同时，我感到很震惊。
Ron feels that The Education of Little Tree is speaking directly to him and to what he believes. But I asked Ron, what if it's the other way around? What if you're the one who's wrong?
罗恩觉得《小树的教育》是在直接对他和他相信的东西说话。但我问罗恩，如果反过来呢？如果你才是那个错了的人呢？
[SIGH] Well, I would like to know myself. If it's what I think it is. What I think it is, I think he wrote it for me, me and my ilk. But I don't know that. Because it's probably been more interpreted the other way-- the other way being the tree hugger way as opposed to my anti-government, anti-cities and government intrusion in our daily lives, that type thing.
[叹气] 嗯，我也想知道。如果这是我想的那样。我想的那样，我想他是为我写的，我和我这类人。但我不知道。因为有更多的人可能把它解读为另一种方式——那种解读方式是“拥抱树木者”的方式，而不是我这种反政府、反城市和政府侵入我们日常生活的方式。
I don't know. I know how I took it. But I also know that there's many or more people took it the other way. Asa Carter. I wish I knew what he thought. I really do. But I honestly don't know.
我不知道。我知道我是怎么理解它的。但我同时也知道有很多人或更多的人以另一种方式理解它。阿萨·卡特。我真希望我知道他在想什么。我真的希望。但我真的不知道。
I don't know myself what to make of the whole thing. But while I was working on this story, I picked up a new copy of The Education of Little Tree and I started to read it to my two daughters. They're loving it. Of course, they don't know the back story. And I'm not sure when I'm going to tell them.
我也不知道该如何理解整件事。但在制作这个故事时，我买了一本新的《小树的教育》，开始读给我的两个女儿听。她们很喜欢。当然，她们不知道背后的故事。而且我不确定什么时候该告诉她们。
For me, it's kind of confusing to read the book and know the history. Like, am I a sucker for just reading it? Every once in a while, I'll come across a passage, like when five-year-old Little Tree sees a hawk kill a young quail. It makes him sad.
对我来说，了解这段历史后读这本书有点困惑。就像，我是因为读它而当了傻瓜吗？每隔一段时间，我就会遇到一段话，比如当五岁的小树看到鹰杀死一只小鹌鹑时。这让他很难过。
So his grandfather teaches him "the way," which is about taking only what you need and about how nature weeds out the small and the slow so the species can grow stronger and more powerful. And I think, is this some white supremacist secret code of racial purity? Or is it just a lovely lesson about the circle of life and not being greedy?
所以他的祖父教他“方法”，也就是只取你所需要的，以及自然如何淘汰那些弱小的和缓慢的，这样物种才能生长得更强壮、更强大。我想，这是某种白人至上主义的种族纯洁性秘密代码吗？还是这只是一个关于生命循环和不贪婪的可爱教训？
A few days ago, I was sharing a pastry with one of my daughters. I tore it in half and held out the two pieces. She chose the small one. And then she looked at me and said, "I have learned the way." For her, the book has nothing to do with small government or racial superiority. It's all about trying to understand people different from yourself, just being a good human being.
几天前，我正在和我的一个女儿分享一块糕点。我把它撕成两半，拿出了两块。她选了小的那块。然后她看着我说：“我已经学会了这个方法。”对她来说，这本书与小政府或种族优越感毫无关系。它全关于试着去理解与自己不同的人，试着做一个善良的人。
Whatever Forrest Carter believed in his heart of hearts, it's safe to say this is a book that Asa Carter would have hated.
无论福雷斯特·卡特内心真正相信什么，可以肯定地说，这是一本阿萨·卡特会痛恨的书。
Joe Richman of Radio Diaries . There's much more from Joe at radiodiaries.org and on the Radio Diaries podcast. We're going to let Asa Carter's old friend from back in the day, Ron Taylor, play us out. He and Asa wrote a song together after Little Tree came out. It was supposed to go in the movie version, but never did.
广播日记的乔·里奇曼。你可以在radiodiaries.org和“广播日记”播客上找到更多关于乔的内容。我们要让阿萨·卡特的老朋友罗恩·泰勒带我们结束。他和小树出版后和阿萨一起写了一首歌。这首歌本应放进电影版，但从未发生。
Oh, I put the melody to it. He did all the words. It doesn't mention Little Tree, but it's about-- it comes from the Little Tree book. [SINGING] Let me tell you a betrayal in Tennessee, see? Is that cabin still a-standing on the ridge, on that mountain standing high against a clear and southern sky?
哦，我为它写了旋律。他写了所有的歌词。它没有提到小树，但它是关于——它来自《小树》那本书。[唱歌] 让我告诉你田纳西州的背叛，看见吗？那个小屋还在岭上屹立吗？在那座高高的山上，在清澈的南方天空下？
One other thing. Joe is in the middle of a Kickstarter campaign right now. If you liked this story and you want more like it, go back him. Kickstarter plus Radio Diaries .
还有一件事。乔现在正处于Kickstarter众筹活动中。如果你喜欢这个故事并且想要更多类似的故事，请去支持他。Kickstarter加上广播日记。
[HUMMING] [SINGING] With that red bone hound a-whining. [HUMMING]
[哼唱] [唱歌] 伴随着那只红骨猎犬的哀鸣。[哼唱]
It's been a long time since I sang! [SINGING] in Tennessee.
我已经很久没唱歌了！[唱歌] 在田纳西州。
[MUSIC - "TENNESSEE"]
[音乐 - "田纳西"]
Coming up, Death. Death is coming up. And death is not who you think it is. That's in a minute from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来是死亡。死亡即将到来。而且死亡并不是你想象中的那样。那是来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的节目，稍后继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Alex Blumberg sitting in for Ira Glass, who's out this week. Today's show, "180." And we've arrived at Act Two. Act Two, Unsafety Exit.
这里是《美国生活》。我是代替艾拉·格拉斯的亚历克斯·布伦伯格，他这周不在。今天的主题是“180”。我们现在来到了第二部分。第二部分，不安全出口。
So you know, every once in a while, someone says, you did a total 360 on that. Like, you did a total 360 on drugs or gay marriage or ferrets. And then someone who knows math will say, it's not a 360. It's a 180. A 180 is when you used to hate dogs and now you love dogs. A 360 would be if you started out hating dogs, then you love dogs, and then you were like, oh yeah, I was right. I do hate dogs.
所以你知道，每隔一段时间，有人会说，你对那个做了360度大转弯。就像，你在毒品、同性婚姻或雪貂问题上做了360度大转弯。然后懂数学的人会说，那不是360度，那是180度。180度是指你过去讨厌狗而现在喜欢狗。360度是指如果你开始讨厌狗，然后喜欢狗，然后你说，噢是的，我是对的。我确实讨厌狗。
The next story is about a person who started out wanting the normal 180, but then actually ends up going for the full 360. Chana Joffe-Walt has our story.
下一个故事关于一个人，他开始时想要正常的180度，但最终却完成了完整的360度。查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）带来了我们的故事。
Michael is a tall, skinny 16-year-old who talks a lot about feelings-- a limited category of feelings, gut feelings. Michael chose turkey for lunch because he had a gut feeling about it. You like his blue shirt? Yeah, he had a gut feeling he should go blue and not red.
迈克尔是一个高高瘦瘦的16岁男孩，他经常谈论感受——一类有限的感受，直觉。迈克尔午餐选择火鸡是因为他对此有直觉。你喜欢他的蓝色衬衫吗？是的，他有种直觉，他应该选蓝色而不是红色。
I don't think about a lot of things. It just comes to me. It just happens. Wherever my road leads me, I go to. I, like-- I follow my road.
我不会想太多事情。它只是来到我身边。它就是发生了。无论路带我去哪儿，我就去哪儿。我，像——我跟随我的路。
Michael's into his road. Brings it up a lot. The first time Michael heard about Lincoln High School, he was in eighth grade, sitting in class, and his teacher mentioned Lincoln had a strong basketball team. Michael had a gut feeling he should be at Lincoln.
迈克尔沉迷于他的“路”。经常提到它。迈克尔第一次听说林肯高中时，他正在上八年级，坐在教室里，老师提到林肯中学有一个强大的篮球队。迈克尔有一种直觉，他应该在林肯中学。
It wasn't that he was unhappy at the store where he was, Union. He liked it. He liked the kids, liked the teachers. But the basketball team was not great. And Michael believed he was destined for the NBA.
并不是他在原来的学校“联合”学校过得不开心。他喜欢那里。他喜欢孩子们，喜欢老师。但篮球队不太好。而迈克尔相信他注定要进入NBA。
His parents were OK with Lincoln. They liked that it had a vocational program. So in August, Michael got a letter that he was in.
他的父母对林肯中学没意见。他们喜欢那里有职业课程。所以在八月份，迈克尔收到信说他被录取了。
Like, how I felt when I got that letter, say you're on a road. Straight ahead, a mile away is the NBA, right there. It's just  a straight path to me. That's how I felt.
就像，我收到那封信时的感觉，比如你在一条路上。直线向前，一英里外就是NBA，就在那儿。对我来说这只是一条笔直的路。我当时就是这种感觉。
If you just follow the road, the NBA is one mile away?
如果你只是沿着这条路走，NBA就在一英里外？
Yeah. And, like, I just couldn't wait to go to school.
是的。而且，我简直等不及去学校了。
The first few months of ninth grade at Lincoln, Michael got to school 20 minutes early and waited outside for the doors to open. He says he woke up excited every morning. He did have a 40-minute commute. That part wasn't great. And from the train he had to cross a park they didn't feel super safe. Also, sitting alone in the cafeteria as a new kid-- he hated that.
在林肯中学九年级的前几个月，迈克尔每天早到学校20分钟，在外面等着大门打开。他说他每天早上醒来都很兴奋。他确实有40分钟的通勤路程。那部分不太好。而且从火车上下来他必须穿过一个他觉得不太安全的公园。还有，作为新学生独自坐在食堂里——他讨厌那样。
But it was all OK, because Michael really felt he was at Lincoln to make his dreams come true. He was on his road. So all that other stuff, it was just gnats to swat away until he could get to tryouts in November.
但这都还可以，因为迈克尔真的觉得他来到林肯中学是为了实现他的梦想。他走在自己的路上。所以其他所有的事情，只是在十一月试训之前需要拍打掉的蚊虫。
I was actually really hyped for it. Every class, I was like, oh yeah, it's tryouts. Next period, tryouts. Last period, tryouts. I just kept saying that. And everybody was like, yeah, we're about to get this.
我当时其实真的很期待。每堂课，我都觉得，噢耶，就是试训。下一节课，试训。最后一节课，试训。我一直说这个。每个人都觉得，耶，我们马上就要搞定了。
Michael showed up in a giant gym, and the coaches started everyone on layup drills.
迈克尔出现在一个巨大的体育馆里，教练们让所有人开始进行上篮训练。
But I kept missing. Then we did left hand. And then I missed every left hand. Then we did shooting. It was bad, really bad.
但我一直投丢。然后我们用左手。然后我左手每一个都投丢了。然后我们进行投篮。太糟糕了，非常糟糕。
What happened?
发生了什么？
Air balls, like the ball kept falling out of my hands. It was just bad. That was the worst I've ever done in my life in basketball.
三不沾，就像球一直从我手中掉下来。太糟糕了。那是我一生中在篮球方面做过的最糟糕表现。
Why do you think you did so badly?
你为什么觉得你表现得那么差？
Probably I was nervous. I did horrible. That's what they looked at me as if I was nothing.
可能是因为我太紧张了。我表现得很烂。他们看着我就像我一无是处一样。
Michael didn't even make the first cut.
迈克尔甚至没有通过第一轮筛选。
Michael has a lot of metaphors to describe the next period of his life. He told me it was like the school was wearing a mask. And after tryouts, the mask came off. In this metaphor, Michael concedes he put the mask on the school. The NBA fantasy, that's the mask. But he says after tryouts, the school was naked and it looked ugly.
迈克尔有很多比喻来描述他生命中的下一个时期。他告诉我，这就像学校戴着面具。而试训后，面具摘下来了。在这个比喻里，迈克尔承认是他把面具戴在了学校身上。NBA幻想，那是面具。但他说试训后，学校赤裸裸的，看起来很丑。
Suddenly he could see everything clearly. He wasn't a mile away from the NBA. He was lonely, far from home in a huge school he didn't like, in a neighborhood he didn't like, in a life he didn't like.
突然间他看清了一切。他离NBA不是一英里远。他很孤独，远离家乡，在一所他不喜欢的大学校里，在一个他不喜欢的地方，在一个他不喜欢的生活里。
He started coming to school late, really late, three hours late. He failed his first period class. And when Michael did show up, he'd just spend all his time thinking about his old school, about Union.
他开始迟到，真的很晚，迟到三个小时。他挂了第一节课。当迈克尔确实出现时，他只会花所有时间去想他的旧学校，“联合”学校。
At lunch, he'd sit there wondering what they were eating back at Union, which field trips they were going on this year. And then at night, he'd go and check Facebook and try to figure out what happened that day at Union. Michael told his principal he wanted to go back to Union. The principal said there's no way to transfer mid-year. He'd have to wait until the summer, and then see if his old school had a spot for him.
午餐时，他会坐在那儿想他们在“联合”学校吃什么，今年他们要去哪些实地考察。然后在晚上，他会去查Facebook，试图弄清楚“联合”学校那天发生了什么。迈克尔告诉他的校长他想回到“联合”学校。校长说学期中不可能转学。他得等到夏天，看看他的旧学校有没有名额。
So Michael did what any 15-year-old does when he doesn't like the answer he's given. He asked again and again. And when he got the same answer, he started asking other people.
所以迈克尔做了任何一个15岁孩子在不喜欢得到的答案时会做的事情。他一遍又一遍地问。当他得到同样的答案时，他开始问其他人。
I kept asking teachers, how could I transfer out? They said, the only way for you transfer out, you got to get a safety transfer. And that's by something that you feel is, like, dangerous around you that you can't be an area.
我一直问老师，我怎么才能转学？他们说，你转学的唯一方法是申请安全转学。那是因为你觉得你所在区域有什么让你感到危险的东西。
Safety transfer. That phrase stuck in Michael's brain, mostly because it included the word transfer. So Michael went back to the principal. What about a safety transfer? Can I get one of those? But Michael says the principal laughed. Safety transfers are for people whose safety has been threatened.
“安全转学”。这个词组在迈克尔脑海中挥之不去，主要是因为它包含了“转学”这个词。所以迈克尔回去找校长。关于安全转学呢？我可以申请那种吗？但迈克尔说校长笑了。安全转学是针对那些人身安全受到威胁的人。
He said, so far you're in good hands, so nothing has happened to you. Like, that I'm safe.
他说，到目前为止你还好好的，什么都没发生。就像，我是安全的。
That's when it clicked for Michael. The only way to get back to his old school was to make himself less safe. So Michael hatched his plan. There were several steps. It begin with a simple purchase.
就在那时，迈克尔灵光一现。回到旧学校的唯一方法是让自己变得不安全。所以迈克尔策划了他的计划。有几个步骤。开始于简单的购买。
OK. I went to a Chinese website, and I bought the hat.
好的。我上了一个中文网站，买了一顶帽子。
Michael bought a winter hat, an NBA one, a beanie with a fuzzball at the top.
迈克尔买了一顶冬帽，NBA的那种，顶端有个绒球的毛线帽。
It was a NBA team beanie, my favorite NBA team, Knicks. Ordered it. Week later, got it. Wore it to school. Get off the train, and I'm making eye contact. I'm trying to make as much eye contact as I can with, like, all the people that kind of looks scary, that had, like, sag in their pants, had chains on.
那是一顶NBA球队的毛线帽，我最喜欢的NBA球队，尼克斯队。订了。一周后，收到了。戴着它去学校。下火车，我正在寻求目光接触。我试着尽可能多地与那些看起来有点可怕、裤子下垂、戴着链子的人进行目光接触。
So I was looking at people. Seeing some kid in the store, right? I just like glared my eyes at him. But, like, I didn't make just eye contact. I stared at them. I counted to three. I said, one, two, three.
所以我盯着人看。在店里看到某个孩子，对吧？我只是用眼睛瞪着他。但是，我不仅仅是目光接触。我盯着他们。我数到三。我说，一，二，三。
Heard, "Yo, boy. Come here." He ran up behind me, tapped me in the chest. I said, "Yeah, what do you want from me?" In the same exact tone. "Yeah, what do you want from me?" He was like, "Yo, you got any money on you? You got your phone on you?"
听到，“嘿，小伙子。过来。”他跑到我身后，拍了拍我的胸口。我说，“是的，你想要我干什么？”用同样的语气。“是的，你想要我干什么？”他说，“嘿，你身上有钱吗？你有手机吗？”
I was like, "No, I don't. Want my hat, though?" He was like, "Actually, yeah. Give me your hat." I gave it to him. He said, "Yo, if you lying to me, if you have your phone or wallet, don't lie to me. You better give it to me, or my squad's gonna jump you."
我说，“没有。不过想要我的帽子吗？”他说，“其实，好吧。把帽子给我。”我给了他。他说，“嘿，如果你对我撒谎，如果你有手机或钱包，别对我撒谎。你最好给我，否则我的兄弟们会揍你。”
Michael did have a wallet in his pocket and an iPod in his sock. So he ran, ran across the street fast-- almost got hit by a truck-- and right into the school.
迈克尔口袋里确实有一个钱包，袜子里有一个iPod。所以他跑了，飞快地跑过马路——差点被卡车撞到——直接跑进学校。
No, it wasn't like, oh, I just got robbed. I need help. It was, yo! I just got robbed! Son, I just got robbed. I got to tell all the teachers. I'm about to get this transfer!
不，那不是像，噢，我刚被抢了。我需要帮助。而是，嘿！我刚被抢了！哥们，我刚被抢了。我得告诉所有的老师。我马上就能拿到转学名额了！
And then all my friends came up to me, like, yo, I heard you got robbed. I was like, yeah, I got robbed! Kids starting telling teachers. Teachers even came up to me, asking, are you OK?
然后我所有的朋友都过来找我，比如，嘿，我听说你被抢了。我说，是啊，我被抢了！孩子们开始告诉老师。老师甚至过来问我，你还好吗？
Went to the principal, told the principal what happened. Went to the precinct, filed a police report. Then I went back to the assistant principal and got my file.
我去找了校长，告诉校长发生了什么。去了警察局，报了警。然后我又回到副校长那里拿到了我的档案。
Did you feel bad at all?
你有感觉一点不好吗？
No, I was feeling good. It was great. I knew what was going to happen next.
不，我感觉很好。那太棒了。我知道接下来会发生什么。
Michael called his old school, told them he got a safety transfer. They said OK. Didn't ask any questions. The principal told me, we didn't want to know. After a couple hours with Michael, I told him I couldn't figure out if what he did was brilliant or so stupid, and that I was settling on both. He said that seemed about right.
迈克尔给他的旧学校打了电话，告诉他们他拿到了安全转学。他们说好吧。没问任何问题。校长告诉我，我们不想知道。和迈克尔聊了几个小时后，我告诉他，我看不出他的所作所为是天才还是太愚蠢，而我最终觉得两者皆有。他说那听起来很对。
Yeah, everything was just coming to me, just fast. Like, my plan, it just went so smoothly and perfect. Like, that's the smartest plan I've came up with so far.
是的，一切都只是来到我身边，很快。比如，我的计划，进行得如此顺利和完美。比如，那是我迄今为止想出的最聪明的计划。
But why did you have to get robbed at all?
但你为什么非要被抢劫呢？
That was the only way I could get a safety transfer.
那是拿到安全转学的唯一方法。
But you could have-- but nobody knew that they took your hat, right?
但你可以——但没人知道他们拿走了你的帽子，对吧？
No.
不。
You could have just put the beanie under your bed at home--
你本可以把毛线帽放在家里床下——
Yeah, that's true.
是的，那是真的。
--and said that you got robbed.
——然后说你被抢了。
That's true too. I don't know why I did it. I don't know. I just felt like I needed the experience. So, like, instead of me just saying, oh, I got robbed. They took my hat. I said, no! I got robbed! They actually took my hat and left, and they ran away with it!
那也是真的。我不知道为什么我非要那样做。我不知道。我只是觉得我需要那种体验。所以，而不是我说，噢，我被抢了。他们拿走了我的帽子。我说，不！我被抢了！他们确实拿走了我的帽子，然后跑掉了，还带着它！
Like, I put more feelings into what I had to say. And, like, I almost fake cried to the police, too. Like, I kept rubbing my eyes.
就像，我对我不得不说的话投入了更多的感情。而且，我甚至差点在警察面前假哭。比如，我一直揉眼睛。
I talked to Michael's mom. She told me she had already started worrying about the neighborhood around Lincoln. On the day she went to pick up Michael, she hated walking through the park by the school. She started to hear kids were getting jumped for their shoes, book bags. So to her, it didn't matter what her 15-year-old son was up to, whether or not he thought he had some plan. What mattered was that he was actually robbed.
我联系了迈克尔的母亲。她告诉我她已经开始担心林肯中学附近的社区了。在她去接迈克尔的那天，她讨厌穿过学校旁边的公园。她开始听说孩子们因为鞋子、书包被抢劫。所以对她来说，她的15岁儿子在捣鼓什么并不重要，不管他是否以为自己有什么计划。重要的是他确实被抢了。
In the middle of ninth grade, Michael went back to Union, right after he turned 15. He says, that is when I fixed my mistake. And if you've ever wondered what it would be like to undo some of the mistakes of your adolescence, to pay attention more in US history, to go unbreak up with that person you broke up with, Michael is here to tell you that it is as awesome as you've always imagined.
在九年级中期，就在他满15岁后不久，迈克尔回到了“联合”学校。他说，那时我修复了我的错误。如果你曾想过撤销青春期的一些错误会是什么样子，比如在历史课上多注意听讲，去和你分手的那个人复合，迈克尔在这儿告诉你们，这和你想象的一样美妙。
Well, remember my first class was algebra. A girl actually grabbed my hoodie. And she said, oh, you look good nowadays. And she said, you're my boyfriend now. She's, like, one of the popular people who actually grabbed my sweatshirt.
嗯，记得我的第一节课是代数。一个女孩实际上抓住了我的连帽衫。她说，噢，你现在看起来不错。她说，你现在是我的男朋友了。她就像那些实际上抓住我卫衣的受欢迎的人之一。
Had she noticed you in eighth grade?
她在八年级时注意到你了吗？
No. I was not cool with her whatsoever. And instead of me being that 5' 5" kid with the light voice, I was that 6' 2" man with a deep voice. I'm like, yo, how's life, blah, blah, blah. I remember walking around. And everybody's like, oh, he's back. He looks way better.
没有。她根本不觉得我酷。而且我不是那个5英尺5英寸、声音尖细的孩子，我是那个6英尺2英寸、声音低沉的男人。我说，嘿，生活怎么样，巴拉巴拉。我记得到处走动。每个人都说，噢，他回来了。他看起来好多了。
And I remember teachers-- I remember walking into the teachers' lounge. And everybody was screaming, It was like, oh! And that was when I knew that that was my welcome back to my old school.
我还记得老师——我记得走进教师休息室。每个人都在尖叫，就像，噢！那时我就知道，这就是我回到旧学校的欢迎仪式。
So you think you made the right decision?
所以你觉得你做了正确的决定？
Yup. It was a gut feeling.
是的。那是一种直觉。
I point out that it was a gut feeling that led Michael to his original mistake to go to Lincoln. But Michael seems to have a gut feeling that he should not listen to that comment. Michael says the way he sees it, the whole thing was just a U-turn on his road.
我指出，正是直觉导致了迈克尔最初去林肯中学的错误。但迈克尔似乎有一种直觉，他不应该听那个评论。迈克尔说他看待这件事的方式，这一切只是他路上的一个掉头。
Chana Joffe-Walt is a producer on our show.
查娜·乔夫-沃尔特是我们节目的制作人。
Act Three, "I'm the One who Knocks." Author Ben Loory has this short story about the 180 that awaits us all. And a quick note to our podcast listeners, there is a curse word that in the podcast we have not beeped. Here's Ben Loory.
第三部分，“我是那个敲门的人”。作者本·卢里有一个关于等待着我们所有人的180度大转弯的短篇故事。给我们的播客听众提个醒，在播客中我们没有对一个脏话进行消音。这是本·卢里。
A man was walking down a long, long road when he saw a figure approaching from the distance. The man kept going, wondering who it was, when suddenly he realized it was Death. "Shit," said the man.
一个男人正走在一条漫长的路上，这时他看到远处有一个身影走过来。男人继续走，好奇那人是谁，当突然意识到那是死神时。“靠，”男人说。
He turned and looked around. There was a tree nearby. One with lots of leaves. So the man ran to it and climbed up in the branches and hid amongst the fruits there, peering out.
他转过身环顾四周。附近有一棵树。树上有很多叶子。所以男人跑向它，爬上枝头，躲在果实中间，向外张望。
After a while, he saw Death coming down the road. He held very still and tried not to breathe. Keep going, he thought. Keep going, keep going. But Death didn't obey. Death stopped.
过了一会儿，他看到死神沿着路走来。他一动不动，努力不呼吸。继续走，他想。继续走，继续走。但死神没有遵从。死神停了下来。
The man felt his heart constrict as death turned to the tree. He felt the blood freeze in his veins as Death looked up. Somehow he knew that despite all the leaves, Death could see him there in his hiding place. How, thought the man. How, if he can't see me, how does he know that I'm here?
当死神转向那棵树时，男人感到心脏收缩。当死神抬头望去时，他感到血液在血管里冻结。不知怎的，他知道尽管叶子茂密，死神还是能看到他在那里的藏身之处。怎么会，男人想。怎么会，如果他看不见我，他怎么知道我在这里？
And then the men realized that in the grip of fear, his hands were shaking, and they were shaking the tree. Oh, god, thought the man. I have to make them stop. He gripped the branches as tightly as he could.
然后男人意识到在恐惧的驱使下，他的手在颤抖，它们在摇晃那棵树。噢，天哪，男人想。我必须让它们停下来。他尽可能紧地抓住树枝。
But the more he tried to hold them still, the more they shook and shook. And the man began to despair. And in the road, Death smiled.
但他越努力让它们保持静止，它们就摇晃得越厉害。男人开始绝望。而在路上，死神笑了。
And right then it happened, the worst possible thing. One of the fruits detached from the tree. The man shaking had loosened it and loosened it and loosened it. And now it broke free and it fell.
就在那时发生了，最糟糕的事情。其中一个果实脱离了树。男人的摇晃不断地松动它、松动它。现在它挣脱了，掉了下去。
And Death saw the fruit fall. And Death came closer until he stood at the very foot of the tree. And he turned his head and looked up through the branches and the leaves until he saw the man and the man saw him. And Death smiled and reached down and picked up the fallen fruit. And he opened his mouth and took a bite.
死神看到了果实落下。死神走近，直到他站在树的根部。他转过头，透过树枝和树叶向上望去，直到他看到了男人，男人也看到了他。死神微笑着伸手捡起了掉落的果实。他张开嘴，咬了一口。
"Yes," said Death, in that voice that Death has. "The unripe fruits are best, I always say."
“是的，”死神用那种死神特有的声音说。“未成熟的果实最好，我总是这么说。”
Panic seized the man. The end, he knew, was near. When Death finished the fruit, he would be next.
恐慌抓住了男人。他知道，末日近了。当死神吃完果实，他就是下一个。
Think, thought the man. Think, think, think. But he couldn't think of a single thing to do. And then from somewhere on the other side of panic, an idea suddenly came to the man. It might work, he thought. It really just might work. And purposely, he began to shake the tree.
思考，男人想。思考，思考，思考。但他想不出任何办法。然后，从恐慌的另一面，一个主意突然闪过男人的脑海。它可能有用，他想。它真的可能有用。他开始故意摇动那棵树。
At first, his efforts had no effect. But the man did not give up. He shook the tree with all the strength he had. He shook the tree with everything, with his entire being. And the little fruits broke free from the tree, and they rained down hard on Death.
起初，他的努力没有效果。但男人没有放弃。他用尽全力摇动这棵树。他用尽所有，用他整个生命摇动这棵树。小果实们挣脱了树，像雨点般狠狠地砸向死神。
"Damn you, Death! Die, die, die!" yelled the man as the fruit smashed against Death's head and face and shoulders. And then with a sudden snap, all the fruits broke free, and they came down like an avalanche. And they buried Death beneath them.
“该死，死神！死吧，死吧，死吧！”当果实砸在死神的头、脸和肩膀上时，男人大喊。然后突然间，所有的果实都挣脱了，它们像雪崩一样落下来。它们把死神埋在了下面。
For a while in the aftermath, there was only silence. And then in the silence, the man thought back. And suddenly he realized that that during the rain of fruit, Death had simply laughed and laughed and laughed. The man stayed in the tree for quite some time, until he was sure it was safe.
之后有一段时间，只有寂静。然后在寂静中，男人回想起来。突然他意识到，在果实雨中，死神只是在不停地大笑。男人在树上待了好一阵子，直到确定安全。
And then when he climbed down very, very slowly, he stood looking at the great mound of fruit. He tapped it lightly with one foot, and the fruits all rolled aside. And there, beneath, there was no Death. Nothing, nobody, not a thing.
当他非常、非常缓慢地爬下来时，他站在那里看着那堆巨大的果实。他用一只脚轻轻地踢了踢它，果实都滚到了一边。那里，下面，没有死神。什么都没有，没有人，什么都没有。
"Well, all right," said the man. "I guess that settles that." And he turned away and hit the road again. Not long thereafter, the man came to a hill. And when he got to the top, he looked down. And there in the valley below, he saw a figure coming towards him. A man, he thought. Just a little man.
“好吧，好吧，”男人说。“我想这就解决了。”他转身又上了路。没过多久，男人来到一座山上。当他到达山顶时，他向下望去。在下面的山谷里，他看到一个身影正向他走来。一个人，他想。只是一个小人。
And at that very moment, the little man looked up. HE saw the man up on the hill and he froze. He turned and looked around, around the valley, panic-stricken. And he saw a nearby tree and he ran. And the man on the hilltop smiled and watched as the little man started to climb. "You think you can hide," said the man, "from me?" And he walked into the valley to see.
就在那一刻，小人抬起头。他看到了山上的男人，僵住了。他惊慌失措地转身环顾山谷。他看到附近有一棵树，跑了过去。山顶上的男人微笑着，看着小人开始爬树。“你以为你能躲开，”男人说，“我？”于是他走进山谷去看看。
Ben Loory is the author of Stories for the Nighttime and Some for the Day.
本·卢里是《夜晚的故事和白天的一些事》（Stories for the Nighttime and Some for the Day）的作者。
Our program was produced today by Ben Calhoun and me, with Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Nikki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Ira Glass is the guy normally in this seat.
我们的节目今天由本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）和我制作，还有肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·富（Stephanie Foo）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、莎拉·柯尼格（Sarah Koenig）、尼基·米克（Nikki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、艾丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普戴克（Nancy Updike）。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。艾拉·格拉斯通常坐在我这个位置。
Production help from Alison Davis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon, our production manager. Elise Bergerson, our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
制作协助：艾莉森·戴维斯（Alison Davis）。塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的行政助理。艾德丽安·马西沃维兹（Adrianne Mathiowetz）管理我们的网站。
Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer.
研究协助：米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）和朱莉·比尔（Julie Beer）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Wayne Greenhaw was interviewed for the Asa Carter in 2011, passed away later that same year.
韦恩·格林豪曾在2011年接受过关于阿萨·卡特的采访，同年晚些时候去世。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
Thanks as always to our show's co-founder, Torey Malatia, who was just at the spa getting ready for his Brazilian beach vacation. Apparently there's a new machine there.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他刚刚在水疗中心准备他的巴西海滩度假。显然那里有一台新机器。
It just bumfuzzled me.
我完全被搞糊涂了。
I'm Alex Blumberg. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是亚历克斯·布伦伯格。艾拉·格拉斯下周会回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。